For San Juan and say thank you so much.
Those an amazing talk.
And I was wondering if
you could elaborate.
What I notice a lot,
I go here to EBC is that a lot
of students and young people,
they're often desensitized to,
for example,
the atrocities that communism or
ideologies that forge terrorism.
And maybe it's some sort of Stockholm
syndrome that I'm seeing where it's like
people are just there,
they're like trapped and they can't do,
they feel in a way they
can't do anything about it.
And then they start to like la,
like like communism or they start to
see more social sort of adopt socialist
policies that in the end
we'll get them killed,
we'll get them hurt.
I was wonder if you kind of like elaborate
on what you think can be done about
that or even if something
can be done in that respect.
Well,
I think something can be done.
I mean I've been trying to educate
people about the horrors of
the Nazi regime and,
and the Soviet regime in particular,
I've concentrated mostly
on those two cars,
but that's good enough.
And trying to let people know that
it was through the fault of people,
much like them,
that those systems are rows and,
and that there are steps you can take
to limit the probability that you would
participate in such a thing and that
those steps are associated with trying to
be truthful in your speech and actions
because the stability of those systems
depends on the willingness
of individuals to lie and,
and also on your willingness to take
responsibility for the malevolence in your
own heart.
That manifests itself in
those social movements.
And so that when I've done,
when I do my lectures,
when I do talks like this,
when I put them on Youtube,
what I'm trying to do is exactly that
because that was the best pathway forward
through such things that I could think
up over 20 years of thinking about it.
Um,
no one is so habituated to suffering
that they can read the Gulag archipelago,
which is actually quite hard to read
without having an effect them like your
psychopathic.
If that book doesn't affect you,
you know,
it should,
if you read it properly,
it affects you deeply.
And it's not the only example
of that kind of literature.
So the people who are habituated aren't,
they've just been shown low resolution
representations of things they don't
understand that looked vaguely bad.
They don't know a damn thing about them.
And our education system has done a
tremendously appalling job of educating
young people about the absolute
catastrophe of radical leftism.
Now it's not much better with regards
to say the actions of the Nazis,
although I would say on average
people are more aware of that,
but they don't.
But it's shallow,
shallow knowledge.
So you make the knowledge deep and deep
knowledge changes people and wakes them
up.
You know?
I mean,
the only reason that I ever got convinced
that they're that good and evil were
real,
more,
more real than anything else,
wasn't because I learned
that God was real.
That's hard.
That's,
that's hard.
It's hard to learn that you have to
find examples of transcendent good.
You know,
they're rare,
evil.
All you have to do is look,
read history a bit and read
it like it's about you.
And there's no way that you can
do that without a transformation.
But people won't do it was like,
do you want to imagine
yourself as an Auschwitz guard?
That's a rough thing you see
because you have to figure out,
see young said,
if you confronted the shadow,
which is the dark side of people,
the aggressive side,
the malevolent side that it,
it really reaches all
the way down to hell.
And Dante sort of was trying to put
four of the same thing when he wrote the
inferno,
right?
With the levels of evil.
Right?
Cause it was a voyage
through the levels of evil,
right to the bottom.
And he thought the bottom was betrayal.
It's pretty good.
The most.
The,
the center of malevolence is betrayal.
I liked that because to be traced someone,
you have to get them to trust you.
And Trust is a moral virtue.
Right?
Especially if it's courageous.
Trust cause it,
it,
it puts you in alignment with other
people in Lousy and to move forward into
life.
And if you'd be trained that you really,
it's like a knife in the,
it's like a knife in the
heart through the back.
Especially if it's someone who loves,
loves you,
betrays you,
and especially if they
betray you for your virtues.
That's a really nice twist.
So
I believe because I think that
people are capable of good,
that if they know enough about evil
that that will straighten them out.
So,
but who wants that?
You know,
this is one of the things
I really like about young.
He's often regarded as a new age thinker.
That's wrong.
He's no new age thinker.
He knew that the,
the pathway to enlightenment was barred
by the necessity of a passage through
hell and that no one was going to do that.
That's why there isn't a world
full of enlightened people.
You might say like if it was just
a matter of doing nice things,
following your blessed,
let's say however you might put it,
then why wouldn't everyone
walk up the stairway to heaven?
That isn't how it works.
That's not how it works at all.
I don't think you can be convinced of
the necessity for moral action until you
understand exactly how dark and terrible
things can get and that it's your fault
that they're getting that way.
Who wants to think that.